Sony vient sortir une nouvelle caméra
c'est le zv1 et d'ailleurs merci à Sony
de me l'avoir envoyé très rapidement
comme ça je peux le découvrir vous avez
un bouton pour venir l'allumer ici pour
l'éteindre bouton pour déclencher le
zoom lancer l'enregistrement vous
choisissez si c'est très simple
également entre de la photo de la vidéo
et vous avez un mode plus intelligent
ici autre truc qui est très cool c'est
que ici vous allez pouvoir venir mettre
un petit micro externe vous avez
également de l'USB C pour venir le
recharger et faire du live stream alors
à la différence de FX3 où je peux mettre
deux cartes à l'intérieur ici j'en mets
une seule mais globalement je pense que
ça fera largement le job et puis ici je
vais avoir un petit HDMI et une prise
casque vous avez un écran qui est
totalement incurvable qu'on peut mettre
dans un sens dans l'autre et lorsque
vous venez l'allumer et bien vous avez
quasiment le même menu que sur le à
cette S3 ou le FX3 vous pouvez aussi
filmer en 4K à 60 images par seconde et
on va pouvoir monter sur 4K 120 images
par seconde on filme en quête de 2 10
bits on est à 2990 euros avec le pack
complet avec le bundle dites-moi si vous
êtes créateur de contenu avec quelle
boîtier vous filmez et est-ce que ce ZV
un e pourrait vous attirer marquez moi
ça bien évidemment dans les commentaires